the world is not empty of the new
and the novel these frontiers this is
how i ended the lecture yesterday there
are just frontiers and frontiers and
frontiers
in chemistry and anthropology and
ethnography
and some of it we're actually talking
about
you know the transformation of the human
form
and not through technology but in a
cleaner
biologically
a way which celebrates natural process
and celebrates the vitality of the
minded
portion of the planet it's an attunement
not this gnostic thing which i evoked
for you which is
you know people used to say of my
grandfather
where he'd been was so so
where he was was hell and where he was
going was paradise
and he lived his whole life that way
well that's a gnostic
attitude you know paradise is just a hit
i think that paradise is a frontier of
language of intentional
communication the reason for looking at
all these things
for looking at the hallucinogens and the
alchemy and the mythology and all this
is because these are the materials
present at hand for an assault on the
citadel
of true being you know somewhere here
there is a clue somewhere here there is
something that we can use it's going to
be an obscure
sect a peculiar mantra a strange drug a
bizarre plan
a forgotten teaching a lost alphabet
something that we can use
so that you know i've talked about the
the
tantric nature of the point of view that
i'm putting out
tantric in the sense of the definition
of
tantra as the short path
taking seriously the idea that in a
single lifetime
a human being might be able to go vast
distances in the project of spiritual
unfolding that you know we are not uh
given or fated to uh
simply incrementally advance ourselves
it is some kind of a lottery i mean
there are
big winners and i'm just very convinced
that the way you enhance your position
in the probability of all of this
is through cognition it will be an act
of understanding
the final act of liberation will be an
act of
understanding okay well that's it for
today folks
there is something totally consuming
about the way
nature builds life out of death
the amazon is a wonderful example of
this
because the amazon is the most living
place you have ever seen
and at any given moment all organic
material
is bound in living systems 95
bound in living systems you don't find
forest
floor detritus and rotting logs and
stuff like that in the amazon
if a leaf falls within minutes or
hours at most it has been found by
leafcutter ants or some other
pathogen that begins to return it
to the cycle of life this kind of
economy
this kind of stability
through utilization of flow
is the design principle that we have
ignored for several thousand years
and that offers a way out
dynamic equilibrium an abandonment of
the possibility of
closure closure is a neurotic
and infantile demand to make
upon reality other people
language you just have to
live in this state of dynamic
disequilibrium which if sustained long
enough an insufficient
taste becomes a life well lived
i mean what are we to make of ourselves
whither mankind
are we to be ultimately viewed as a
cosmic accident
the the perils of unfocused
intelligence or can we reflect
the inner dream the inner image of
wholeness that inspires us and makes us
more than animals
and raises us up as a simulacrum of the
goddess
that's what i would hope for and
thought cognition planning
caring emotion communication
intentionality focus
and authenticity are the domains
that we have to be in in order to carry
this off
you wanted challenge some of you have
made fortunes that was no
challenge you wanted a challenge
save the planet there's a challenge
that's what everybody who came before
did they participated sufficiently at
least to pass the buck to us
can we participate sufficiently to pass
the buck to our grandchildren
or are we just going to go down as the
lamest
generation in the life of the planet
i can't believe it i know too many of
these people i love
too many of these people we just need
to do our best as the grateful dead
say you know just a little bit harder
just a little bit more you can't go back
and you can't stand still if the thunder
don't get you then the lightning
will so forward
into the future with a high heart
and reasonable hope that we can make
this planet
into a living reflection of the inner
dream
well i i think anybody who didn't have
some kind of fairly
strong model of what is going
on would be scared to death i mean there
is a sense of everything
simply flying apart we don't know what
it will be
world economic crash ebola outbreak
asteroids strike climate change but
it just begins to multiply to the point
where you get the feeling we may not
know what's coming but god something
must be coming so a thousand years
is reaching its culmination and
inevitably this civilization
will be divided at this millennium
that will be the first millennium of
industrial
post medieval so forth and so on and
this
and then whatever comes after even the
most rational among us
can hardly fail to notice that
we are we have backed ourselves into one
hell of a position and how are we going
to get through this
and maintain our human dignity i mean
are we going to
allow millions billions of people to
slip into starvation and disease
are we going to practice triage on
entire sectors of the planet
and withdraw resources so that the
the uh white industrial
democracies can ride through the waves
of
chaos i mean it's very important that
we not only preserve the human genome
it's important that we
preserve human values
through all of this and i think
realizing
that we are caught in a process of
metamorphosis
and transformation not of our
responsibility
is the basis for uh the attitudes of
confidence and
anticipation that that will be necessary
and that will allow us to be exemplars
for the society something so
extraordinary is happening
on this planet i mean you know for
hundreds of millions of years biology
flowed across the surface and species
advanced and retreated and
sensory organs were refined and
redefined and so forth and so on
but about 35 50 000
years ago language broke loose and
language is the sheer will of
information itself
to transform itself i mean we are
uh our medium is meat
but we are made of information
you know and that information could be
fed into a computer crystallized into a
virus
what we are is a long message
that is being typed out in proteins by
thousands of ribosomes
coordinated over time we are sort of
like a phonograph record
and when you're young you know certain
enzyme
systems certain genes are turned on and
then you pass into midlife
other genes are turned on certain genes
are turned off
it's like a melody theme and variation
being brought back the theme being
enriched and worked and then finally
the whole thing builds to a crescendo
and then one by one the jeans are turned
off and
the audience tugs on its overcoats and
cabs are hailed and people go home for
the evening but
that that's what you are you're a story
a piece of code
being run in the great computer of
of the world but nothing lasts
you know not your friends not your
enemies
nothing lasts and we deny this
and yet that's the great psychedelic
truth and if you can face it in every
moment and live it
you will have a very very complete
experience of existence
you will ride the dao towards the
concrescence and be able to live in the
light of its anticipation
and this i believe makes for
a healthy life full of lots of laughs
[Music]
you